i want to start with congrats on your
movie um i really enjoyed it i thought
you did a great job so this is like your
first time making like a bigger movie
and making an adam sandler movie and
what surprised you about working with
him and like working for netflix i think
the biggest surprise is how much it's
like making a small independent film i
think you know it's it's all the same
mechanisms it's all the same job you
know it's hard as hell and it's just you
know you're just trying to get through
the day and you're hoping that you know
it's it's it's good enough to make the
cut what you're shooting
it honestly what's surprising is how
similar it is so no matter what money no
matter what you have it's the same
challenges and obstacles all the same
[ __ ] yeah it's just trying to get real
emotion
and you know
real vibes on screen i mean that's
really what it is i enjoyed the way you
shot it and like the visual aesthetic
that you went for can you sort of talk
about working i believe your
cinematographer's name is zach um can
you talk about working with zach on how
you wanted the aesthetic of the film the
color choices and all that yeah i mean
zozak and i have been working together
for
10 15 years i mean
a long time
um we started working together on a
sports film a short sports film called
always a fire that i directed with a guy
named nathan caswell
and we did we the animals together and i
think that you know generally the ethos
of our aesthetic is make it real
you know we we want to make it real and
then we want to elevate that reality so
that's what we tried to do and we
watched every sports film we possibly
could um and we watched every basketball
film we possibly could
and then we thought how how can we make
it different how can we make it
interesting and how can we get into the
the minds of the basketball player and
the mind of stanley um and we developed
as many techniques as we could to do
that you know we worked with our
colorist seth reichardt um at rco um
and
um
you know we we tried to create a filmic
look on digital um i think we did a
pretty good job um
and then you know
on top of that we wanted every
basketball game to have its own feel and
its own vibe so we would plot out each
basketball game to give it its own thing
you know whether
you know that would be getting inside
wancho's head in the 515 or
you know
using as many multimedia formats as you
can in the um
boa challenge or you know making sure
that everything was smooth
as could be for the final game you know
all these
different um games required a different
aesthetic sense um and therefore
different techniques
you know
and and i think you know the overriding
technique was get in and get close
build as much as you could to get as
close to the basketball players as
possible to be inside the game because
you know we watched on tv we're we're on
the outside looking in um so we built
this thing called a charlie bar that um
stuck out from the um the player's
stomachs
dedicated to our key grip charlie and it
pointed back at uh
at the player so that they were looking
directly into the camera as if they were
playing ball against you the viewer we
had a a tiny little remote control car
called a terror that our second unit dp
ran um tim sessler and it would spin
around the court and under people's legs
and such um and then we built you know
crazy contraptions like a plexi glass
floor that the basketball players could
play on and we put a camera inside a
basketball you know we did as much as we
could to um you know
change it up so that it felt different
and new
for the viewer what did you learn from
any like friends and family screenings
or any test screenings that impacted the
finished film i screened it for my
family for my mother and father and my
mother said my favorite stuff is the
basketball and my mother doesn't know
anything about basketball so you know we
knew we'd gotten that right um
you know she also i'll tell you i'll
tell you a story my mother i also the
first time i read it for her i screamed
for her twice the first time i screened
it for she didn't understand what
stanley did and why it would be
bet why it were worse than being a coach
and it was based on the structure she
was like i don't know
you know he gets to travel around the
world and stay in fancy hotels why does
he want to be a coach
it doesn't seem very good to be a coach
you stay home you have to work all the
time
and it was it was a structural thing it
was it was how we uh we needed to front
load the experience of how miserable he
was as a scout and so you know that that
that comment from my mother changed the
edit is that did you build that montage
at the beginning of
because of your mom's comment that
montage used to come later in the film
um
it used to come you know at the end of
act one and and we put it right up front
because of my mother yeah so i'm almost
out of time i'm trying to think what
would have happened if the 76ers had
said no
how
i don't know i haven't know yeah it
would have been a disaster
i'm just like i'm just i'm i'm sure
another they had to say i mean you look
they had to say yes they they're my team
uh
you are from philly and i'm curious what
did you were there certain locations or
places or things from the city that you
knew that you're like i have to effing
put this in the movie this these are
locations that have to be included yeah
absolutely there's a and they're all in
the movie you know what was cool is that
you know adam was super receptive to
you know wherever i wanted things to be
and how
where i where i wanted to stage things
you know he knew i knew the city and he
knew it was my city and
and he was open to it and that was cool
you know like like the court of
passangino's we we knew it was the
perfect court the way it was lit i'd you
know i'd walked by his you know a
thousand times as a kid and you see it
at night it's amazing you know or you
know that that maniac wall you know
those streets and how they work you know
the other thing is we had a wonderful
location scout troy coffey who lives
like down the street from my parents so
we knew the same same stuff you know and
he anytime i said oh no i want it to be
like this or i want to find that hot
spot you know that spot where blah blah
blah blah blah blah oh yeah yeah yeah it
was like a second hand we you know we
just we just knew you had a lot of nba
players in the movie way more than i
expected who surprised you with their
acting ability
who surprised you
i thought actually everyone did a really
good job
everybody's great no no i mean i i
didn't i didn't i wasn't taken out of
the movie at any point like ooh this
performance is
i'll tell you what i knew wancho was
gonna be great because we'd worked with
him for years you know and i had an idea
that anthony edwards is going to be
great but then when we got him in the
first scene
and we did that wonder where the camera
moves around him i did not know he was
going to be that great
i think his performance is
paul newman good um you know adam and he
kept saying he's paul newman like where
where does this guy's charisma come from
i mean he is a shockingly confident
actor um i think it's also him as a
player
he is he's that way as a player but i
think that role is a simple role and he
elevates it he takes it to a place um
you know of a great anti-hero and i i i
was shocked by that
and that don't i need to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the movie i
look forward to what you do next thank
you very much man cool have a great day
nice to meet you
you